[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Heather
joins us up next in Baltimore Heather
what's going
on hi I'm calling to figure out next
best steps um my husband and I we' been
married about 20 years about I'd say 10
years ago we did the Financial Peace
University we were in a ton of debt and
we did that for a while and then we got
distracted and stopped working on it but
happily now even though we didn't pay
attention for a while we are out of debt
than our house um I have a six month
emergency fund and everything and
recently I got an inheritance um from
the passing of my father um for some
extra cash so where we're at now um we
have we bought our house 15 years ago
it's 170ish years old whoa and my
biggest argument is stop watching HGTV
before you buy a house because it was
the stupidest thing we've ever done so
so you thought we're going to turn this
into some Victorian
dream maybe not that but we just thought
we could do a lot more than we have in
15 years so okay I'm very aware I this
is I even take all the blame because
this is 100% on me this how well he
signed on but um so where we're at now
um my my husband has always always
wanted to build a sizable Workshop um he
has hobbies that are big heavy machinery
and he's slightly hoard hoarder is um
that's a good combo really expensive
Machinery plus hoarding not as expensive
they're just big um so right now we have
about $20,000 or so from The
Inheritance and he clearly wants to go
forward on the building the workshop
because the plan always was build the
workshop then we would have the re the
space to solve other house problems I
have been here long enough to know that
my house needs too much like our
foundation massive issues like you know
everything is old nothing is
everything's basically going to need
replaced at some point in fact it's
needed replaced so just sell your house
sell your house that's that's what I am
talk thinking we should do like it would
be smarter to sell our house and find
another house the area we live in
Maryland is an incredibly High Cost of
Living area just sell your house just
sell your house what could it sell for
as is without you putting all this work
into it um I might be able to get
$20,000 out of what over what we owe
what do you owe 190 and you've lived
there 15 years we bought it at 2007
right when the market crashed so it took
a long time just to get back to what we
owed just sell your house and we didn't
put down so sell your house I I'm I'm
there the other concern I have is that I
really like our mortgage where at now
like I he was a hey Heather sell your
house sell your house I'm on that so I I
want to do that it's just but to buy
another house I'm looking at like
400,000 450 other houses that I could
convince my husband to move into okay
here's another idea I just thought of it
don't sell your house okay
uhuh
Tada how does that hit
you well that's the other one I'm at but
then I have to spend all the money
either like I I still can't I got a new
idea I got a new idea F the house I have
a new idea sell your house and we're
back like here's the deal there's not a
right or wrong here you have just
Twisted yourself up like a pretzel oh I
have yes that was tricky John what you
just did do what you talked about the
anxiety thing my $1,500 a month mortgage
doesn't give me anxiety anymore a new
house another $ th000 a month mortgage
on top of that does but thing you're
forgetting that, 1500 is not 1500 it's
going to be 150,000 because of what
you're going to have to do to this place
over the next decade but if you put if
you just got a $100,000 inheritance and
you put a $100,000 into that house it
will appreciate for
what um in a high cost of living area
would it would would it double would it
be worth 350 to 400,000
bucks no know because the money that
would put into it is is like the
invisible stuff that still just gets it
back from not falling down anymore okay
here's an idea ,000 into it I'm probably
getting close to 300 to 350 maybe okay
which which almost doubles it well at
200 now but yeah okay what would it cost
to rent somewhere let's say you sold it
you have 140 you keep saving and saving
on top of that what if for one year you
rented
saving would your husband go for that or
does it crush his dreams not for 5
seconds
why he has stuff problems okay well
let's deal with the stuff problems
problems putting ourself in a terrible
financial position here's what I think
can I tell you can I just say what I
think you tell me if I'm wrong say
you're an idiot and you're wrong I
think your marriage is not as good as
you're letting on and I also think and
maybe your marriage isn't bad you and
your husband are in two very different
pages y are great co-managers of your
house your
roommates and you have some other stuff
going
on and this is a big uh marryg go around
that you can get on and go around in
around and contemplate all the reasons
you should stay and all the reasons you
should go and what it allows you to do
is avoid dealing with the scary scary
truth sitting inside your house probably
sitting on your couch right next to you
there could be relevance there
but there could be relevance there that
awesome this isn't going anywhere right
all right so if I were to take on
additional mortgage no no no no no we're
not doing I'm my house okay listen to
back to that what about this what about
taking your husband off for dinner and
saying honey I plan us a
date and sat down and said I'm scared to
death about the trajectory of our
marriage
I want to get you a barn but how you
spend money and your addiction to stuff
scares me and the fact that I'm running
really low some might call it depression
and I'm anxious a lot scares
me I'm scared our house is going to fall
down I'm scared we can't afford to move
I can't breathe in this
house what if you did that I just felt
my shoulders drop just saying that for
you this wouldn't be a conversation okay
then you have to deal with that reality
and selling your house or not selling
your house is not you and your husband
are going to go with you to your new
house yes you and your husband are going
to go with you when you build a shop
that you can't
afford well that's not
happening because I won't say yes to
that yeah him having this dream workshop
solves zero problems yes so we need to
deal with a Rude problem which number
one is we are way far away on our values
when it comes to our dreams and vision
financially so we need to align on that
first before we make any
decision and if we can't find an
alignment on that it's worth reaching
out to a third party our friends at
better help we need to get to the root
of this cuz if he still has his
addiction to stuff we're going to be
broke three years from now regardless of
what we do you sound really close to
resentment it's not resentment what is
it this is been here for a long this I I
this is our reality you've resigned I
can't change another person I can choose
to make decisions going forward based on
the reality that exists like or I
obviously could leave but that's not an
option okay um so
but I the only thing that stops me
really from trying to buy a different
house
is that then brings on like it just
makes money Tighter and we were a single
income family for a long time for the
last few years we've not been and it's
amazing to not feel stressed about money
anymore mhm I like that so some
sometimes when I've had a house that I
just want to get out of really bad yeah
I sometimes overinflate just how the
house is falling down it's gonna fall
down I promise I'm not no no no I'm just
I'm just saying what I did not what you
do I would go through that list of
questions like the things that you think
have to be done the things that you had
planned to do because of httv back in
the day and then the chip and Joanna
things that would make it amazing like
make a list of those
things and put real not imaginary put
real dollar amounts to them and just see
what you're talking about because right
now you have no data you have a storm
that just is on on repeat in your mind
and it your body's keep your body's
wearing out because of it um sit down
with real numbers and real stuff and
then see what this looks like I don't I
don't know another option for you
because you said you've had the hard
conversation with your husband and he
doesn't he'd rather have his big toys
than have a wife that feels loved and
safe and so as George said you're going
to have to deal with a marriage
counselor at some point but I would love
for you to sit down and say okay let's
get serious about answering the
questions about this house let's that's
going to allow us to get serious about
what we do next but I'm telling you
right now these imaginary conversations
you're having over and over and over in
the loop and the what if but then what
if and then the what if you're driving
yourself into an early grave you're
worth more than that create your free
every dollar budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life